Memories are fragile.
I want us to sketch out the right man.
We just need enough details
for someone who knows him.
It won't work. No one knows him.
Found her this morning.
The city workers found a body
from a young woman called Julia.
Six years ago, I was cut up like her.
What someone did to Julia,
they tried to do to you.
If you're trying to be a reporter,
then this is your story.
After what he did...
things weren't how they should be.
It starts with little things...
and then big things.
And nobody remembers anything different.
There are multiple women dead
over multiple decades.
He's the one connecting them.
There'll be more.
I don't know how,
but he's been watching me
since I was a kid.
He's everybody.
He's nobody.
He's all the time.
Why are you doing this?
Just because something hasn't happened,
doesn't mean it won't.
We're all connected.
Things changed for me just like that.
And then it happens again.
And again.
You shouldn't be here.
What's his name?
Who's the man who visits you?